[Música]
y yo quiero hablar de noto miedo y me
encuentro muy a gusto aquí en esta
tribuna que pisa varias veces para
hablar del desarrollo económico de la
zona que para los que no son de aquí se
llama a mariña lucense y la última vez
que estuve aquí fue para leer unas
páginas los otros gigantes de algo lo
con queiro
cuándo
felipe merlo de venir aquí a hablar de
resiliencia de entrada a mí se me vino a
la mente el concepto ingenieril de
resiliencia por deformación propia pero
el concepto ingeniería de resiliencia es
la energía de deformación que puede ser
recuperada importante esto de un cuerpo
deformado cuando cesa el esfuerzo que
causa la deformación
evidentemente
a puntada de determinadas ideas que
pueda decirte seguirá profundizando más
en el concepto y encontrado que la
residencia es la capacidad de superar la
adversidad o la capacidad de los seres
humanos para adaptarse positivamente a
situaciones adversas
evidentemente en mondoñedo ha pasado por
situaciones adversas o está pasando
todavía por situaciones adversas
mondoñedo era un municipio de 11.000
habitantes en este momento tiene poco
más de 4000 era un municipio con una
industria maderera boyante y este
momento han cerrado todas las
instalaciones para el tratamiento de la
madera aunque habéis visto que hay
grandes bosques con muchos eucaliptos
pero falta la fuerza transformadora
tengo un seminario que lleva a tener
300 alumnos en este momento no tiene
ninguno
[Música]
ahora hay gente entusiasta que trata de
aprovechar la oportunidades puesto que
no está presente por dificultades puedo
decir que la alcaldesa es una de las
personas que con más entusiasmo y que
estás tratando de aprovechar todo lo que
puede tratar de convertir los contentos
antiguos esto era un convento y hoy es
un auditorio pero ahí arriba en lo alto
del monte de otro convento que se quiere
convertir en un motel o aprovechar el
camino de santiago que pasa por aquí o
aprovechar otra serie de cosas a mí se
me ocurrió que hay algo más y permite
meter un poco atrás cuando no está
ninguna paz desde hace muchísimo tiempo
cuando la invasión de los normandos la
tele episcopales estaba en san martín de
hemos venido relativamente cerca por
donde hemos pasado yo los que hemos
estado en la playa de las catedrales
había un obispo dice eso entra dentro de
la leyenda no está comprobado
históricamente sangonzalo que cuando las
invasiones de los normandos él se ponía
a rezar y cada vez que rozaba una
ovación al forma de un barco normando a
pesar de todo no debieron tener
demasiada confianza en las oraciones del
san gonzalo si es que existió
y trasladado en la sede aquí entonces se
llevaba vía mayor y desde entonces
mondoñedo por el siglo del siglo 11
empieza a estar en el mapa vuelve a
estar de una forma muy presente en el
mapa
en el siglo 15 cuando el mariscal pero
pardo de zela se rebela contra isabel de
castilla
isabel de castilla manda a ejecutar lo
de la última hora
le concede el perdón y manda al
necesario a mondoñedo para que realmente
suspenda en la ejecución lo que sucede
es que había un par de canónigos con
nombres y apellidos que está
perfectamente documentado en algún libro
publicado recientemente
que no eran amigos precisamente del
mariscal pardo de zela y laurent van a
detener al emisario en un puente que
está muy cerca de donde hemos comido en
muchos de nosotros hoy en los molinos
que se llama punto de paso o apunte que
en gallego es femenino a postre de pasao
tiempo
[Música]
es otro momento en los que está
realmente
en el mapa cien años después más o menos
cervantes para hacer un homenaje
al obispo que daba según dice el
escritor ramón loureiro
cita en el prólogo del quijote al obispo
de manejo de pueblos funciones que no
eran muy propios de sus oficios pero ahí
queda citado el obispo de mondoñedo en
el problema de el quijote que todos lo
podéis ver si cogéis el que joden en
nuestras manos o sea el mundo está en el
mapa hace mucho tiempo pero hay mucha
gente que seguramente y sobre todo la
gente joven que no sabe quién era el
mariscal por la parte de cela ni san
gonzalo
y a lo mejor ni siquiera ha leído el
quijote o se han saltado el prólogo
entonces montaña debe estar
en el mapa y lo ha puesto la niebla
y vamos a ver cómo podemos aprovechar la
oportunidad
pensando en esto me acordé de un hecho
que sucedió en el año 1973 algunos no
habían nacido de lo que estáis por aquí
en el año 1973 después de la guerra del
yom kipur la tercera guerra que se
organiza entre los israelitas y los
palestinos se produce la primera gran
crisis del petróleo la segunda serie ya
con unos cuantos años después con
señores jomeiní
como consecuencia de esa primera crisis
del petróleo en lata tiembla y tiempo de
frío porque no hay petróleo para
calentar las las calefacciones y se
toman una serie de medidas para reducir
el consumo del petróleo una de ellas en
españa' de albarreal que en aquel
momento no se ha visto en mucho caso
pero una de ellas es el cambio de
horario es cuando se produce el cambio
de bario en primavera y en otoño yo era
entonces un joven
ingeniero que estaban en renfe en edad
de merecer y ahí nos encontramos con un
problema y cómo se resuelve el problema
el problema es que cuando se retrasa una
hora qué pasa con los trenes los trenes
no pueden salir antes de la hora de vida
establecida en el itinerario de la
estación entonces la decisión que nos
pareció cómoda a los que no estábamos
metidos directamente en la gestión del
movimiento sino yo estaba en ese aumento
en planificación estratégica
nos parece que es muy simple pero la
braza es que sigue haciéndose parar los
trenes una hora donde en la estación
donde lleguen con ese motivo se hicieron
varias cosas pero había una persona
porque simultáneamente nosotros en ese
momento teníamos un concurso de relatos
breves que se llamaba antonio machado
y vuelvo a decir cómo era yo un joven
ingeniero en edad de merecer pues me
llamaban casi todas las cosas y me
nombraron jurado de ese premio y llevo
un relato que explica con muchos
pormenores que había hecho una pequeña
estación en la línea para aprovechar esa
hora en que él expresó que no paraba
jamás allí iba a parar durante una hora
los montan una serie de fiestas preparan
una serie de empanadas supongo que pulpo
a feira todo lo que queráis hasta aclare
por qué estás para entretener durante
esa hora
a estos señores esto mismo pensarán y en
la niebla
ayer los que hemos venido de madrid
hemos dejado la autovía no era necesario
por la niebla pero donde se deja
habitualmente con está y niebla
y no se pasa en ese momento se pasa por
cerca de mondoñedo nosotros nos hemos
metido directamente a mondoñedo pero
había una curva grande donde si no
hubiésemos tomado esa curva para entrar
en el miedo nos hubiésemos ido por el
valle y tampoco hubiésemos entrado nadie
ya mí se me ocurre que cerca de esa
curva y un poco más arriba y esto lo
digo para los mindonienses que están
aquí y para la gente emprendedora de
mondoñedo para los de turismo para los
los restauradores hay que poner unos
grandes carteles y ofrecer las grandes
oportunidades que tiene mondoñedo para
pasar un buen rato en mondoñedo
aprovechando que por la nieve nos han
bajado por aquí
ese es el mensaje que yo quiero dejado y
que mañana la repetiré cuando a la
alcaldesa porque creo que hay que
aprovechar esa oportunidad para el
desarrollo del montañero hay muchas
cosas tenemos la catedral se está
terminando el museo de coke y yo la
calle con tiro a la orilla hemos estado
esta mañana
tenemos los molinos donde hemos estado
comiendo que se llama aquí poéticamente
la avenencia muy in donde sé por qué no
se suele fijado que tiene un montón de
riachuelos y canales por todos lados hay
cantidad de cosas que ver en mondoñedo
tenemos el museo diocesano
el museo catedral y todo eso hay que
ofrecerlo y si conseguimos además hacer
en los picos un buen bottle será posible
traer a la gente y hacerle pasar aquí
algún tiempo porque la gente que pasa
por mondoñedo se enamora de mondoñedo y
vuelve a mondoñedo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]